are you doing your sketch shows on
youtube uh
we're trying yeah yeah we're gonna try
to get some new ones going everyone says
how funny your schedule is but it takes
uh we gotta get funding
so yeah that's time was that the idea
like the first batch of them was like
let's show people what we should do
yeah because i i had gotten cancelled
that's right i forgot about that so
people were a little hesitant to give me
the green light right but now so we
wanted to show that we can make stuff
right and uh yeah it's going all right
hopefully we can get some and also we
put a lot of money into the first
so it'd be weird to take a big step back
production-wise did you do a season or
how many did you do we did uh i don't
know like eight episodes but they were
all sketches so basically the equivalent
of like two
full episodes okay you just put sketches
out okay yeah yeah and you're doing it
with how many people
i mean we had a
production team so there was a lot there
was a lot of people we might have
overdone it on that i mean there were
like food trucks and [ __ ]
isn't this going on youtube
i'm not comfortable enough to hire up
like there's something i want to get
done i'm not comfortable enough to hire
a product i have no confidence to do
that in all the years of music are you
worried that the production team is
going to be like this sucks or no but no
i mean i wouldn't i wouldn't know where
to get them like i'm so oh well yeah
yeah i mean i'm totally incompetent i
mean it's all john mcever the other guy
he's the one he's good at setting things
up he can write direct he can [ __ ]
act he's put the whole thing together
him in a production company called
booklight you need that right you need
somebody who's good at that stuff
because some people who are funny are
really good at i'm so luis gomez is
amazing to me because he's such a
[ __ ] he's so good at like having a
business run and starting things up and
like i i just none of that could
accomplish yeah i can't do anything but
that's why you hire a producer right
that's what a producer does
in theory but i mean i mean that's a
good point that's a good point
but then because i don't know how
anything works i slowly start to resent
the producers right like i'm like what
do they even do
i could have done all this
you can't do a single thing
but it's all that basic [ __ ] that's hard
to do or that's what you just don't want
to do that never gets done yeah never
yeah it really doesn't but yeah yeah you
just have to you have to find one guy
who can do everything
and then let them do it john mckeever
did right right he's he's brilliant yeah
it helps to have someone who likes doing
it it's not a big truth because then you
don't feel guilty like they're expecting
you to do half of that work yeah i'm
never gonna do that i can't i'm not it's
not my my mind doesn't work that way did
you like doing all the sketches or was
it a lot of work like really really fun
yeah there were some episodes there were
some sketches that sucked like there's
one where i i'm on a [ __ ] sibian
and i had to sit on the sibian for the
entire shoot which took like three hours
yeah and i haven't done that before
so my inner thighs were just destroyed
i was like shaking doesn't accident kind
of rock a girl into coming yeah all
right yeah i was starting to do
something with the sippy but i never saw
it it's like an electric saddle
vibrating oh yeah he's a howard stern
[ __ ] classic is that yeah i remember
hearing about he would talk about it but
i just i never thought it was just bring
ladies into the studio toss them on a
sibian interview while they're coming
does it work though does a girl come
from it yeah yeah it's like a super
deluxe vibrator yeah it's top of the
line dude but it's a saddle right yeah
but it's kind of it's like they're
riding they're on top and oh yeah okay
gets in there can we see what one of
them looks like yeah fire this up dude
travis just show him the one you got
yeah
spice things up a lot
do you like stuff like that with a girl
like toys and [ __ ] like that i never big
on toys no i no it kind of makes me
uncomfortable it seems cool until you're
in the room yeah that's just weird no no
like you're kind of gross
this is gross that you do this i'll tell
you what i hate i hate when a woman puts
her fingers in her [ __ ] and then shoves
them in my mouth for many reasons really
but yeah
it's happened a lot but i just never
i just never liked it to like eating
[ __ ] i always enjoyed yeah um when the
girl has one but i don't like uh the
finger in the [ __ ] in the mouth i just
never
it was a gesture that was supposed to be
sexy that i never
quite enjoyed yeah i guess i don't like
fingers in my mouth
but it hasn't happened to you that much
no i think i put off a vibe that's like
nothing's going in
i'm just
yeah where jim is like feels more like a
receptacle like everything you're like
i'm not saying that yeah yeah no he's
not wrong i mean this is nice though oh
yeah this is pretty cool good other than
that one on the left pretty cool
the one on the left is one of those
weird automatic [ __ ] things i forget
what it's called but it just like pumps
a dildo it just seems dangerous it is
weird though like you're with a person
who owned it before you
like it's like it's if a couple buys it
together
then you can almost justify it like oh
this is wild we're about doing this new
but when you meet somebody and they're
like oh i have this thing and the
sybians know
look at the size of that [ __ ] thing
right you got to put that in the closet
like that takes up a lot of space yes
you're dating a real
trash lady
like i mean that's a [ __ ] tough one
and you can change the tops can you
change the top yeah oh there you go
yeah it has to be a huge part of your
life yeah you know to take up that much
space in your house
it's pretty brilliant actually you're
gonna get one you won't no i've never
i've never i told you i tried [ __ ] i
bought a couple of those [ __ ] torsos
right over my just to try
a
to
get
couple yeah i threw one out not long ago
it was very i threw two out actually
tough to throw out
because they're weird to carry down the
hallway yeah live in the [ __ ]
manhattan apartment walking down this
it's it's because the bottom is flat
right so it just feels gross and weird
but it would put it down in a chute yep
yes i did
you can you hear that i mean that seems
like a heavy oh yeah yeah it really felt
it was very heavy it was like a 911
jumper
that thing
[Laughter]
yeah it was [ __ ] uh it was it was
embarrassing
walking down the hall yeah yeah
i had a flashlight i had to get rid of
it dude it was too powerful yeah it was
too powerful yeah i thought it was
[ __ ] this thing constantly like what
am i doing did you take working like for
me i've had a bunch of those things and
i i could never because i'm so weird
when i jerk off like i could never just
get into the motion of [ __ ] i just
felt sick oh no i was just whacking off
but it was still like was it like a
deluxe one or is it just a standard
regular one yeah i think i don't but it
was uh
yeah i was living on like a mattress in
west philly mm-hmm with a bunch of other
comments i literally i didn't even have
like sheets on a mattress just laying
there
yeah it was a real rock bottom moment
yeah also my friend got one he was the
one matt bought two
and he tried to lie the package came i
was playing video games and the doorbell
rang and he was he goes yes and he ran
to the door and i go what is it he goes
i don't know
and then then he goes i got a flashlight
and i was like what and he goes i got
two do you want i was like yes dude this
is great
then i had to throw in a dumpster you
got rid of it yeah yeah i've tried them
i never uh and i bought these one things
because i was i was getting these weird
things on my dick because i like i
jerked off so much i lost some
sensitivity so i was having these shots
and i wound up getting this um
i haven't done it in over like probably
two years or whatever but or a year and
a half but you get into this
what are you talking about no it was
before it was whatever before covered i
got it right two years yeah it's never i
don't want you to i know it's like your
story so it's it doesn't feel as
interesting but you never feel like you
can't revisit the penis electrolysis
stuff yeah i just like to know yeah i
think what it does is if you jack off
like i kind of quit jacking off because
it [ __ ] you up so much like your dick
just gets numb um or or it's harder
to come because the mo you're used to
jerking off you used to the grip my own
thing it was doing it a lot oh yeah
what's uh just sorry what's a lot just
not only every day but edging like not
coming and just it was just an addictive
show like every day for how long a day
hard on and off like literally start
with a little while stop go to the
seller come back finish
so when you say edge like you would edge
and then stop and then go to work yeah
and then come home and continue [ __ ]
you're coming to the cellar loaded no
it goes away like it would kind of go
down and then come back so i went to
this place but technically a lot of
people like there will be people that
jerk off
before they do something to be like let
me get that out of my system okay that's
done check that box now i can go yeah i
can go do this set i can go like
everything that happened in your day was
mid jerk off it was it there were days
like that yeah so
those days would occur oh yeah uh it
would do that to you so i i want to have
like cutting down on sensitivity so you
get these pr these are and just for
saying too um yeah it would cut down
your uh sensitivity so you they wand
your dick
and it puts little shocks in your dick
um
and that that helps heal it the teeny
the minuscule blood vessels that burst
it promotes healing whatever so you get
a couple shots so i bought these things
and it worked though you're saying yeah
it does really help i mean and then you
quit jerk it off that helps you and then
you want to get in these things they
look like fleshlights but you pump them
and they pull air into your dick and
that means they they kind of help you
dick fill with blood like a penis pump
like austin power and you leave it on
yeah for like 10 minutes and it helped
it was great your dick looks great a
deck pump yeah i would think it could
show it off like that all the time
your dick in a dick pump is phenomenal
did you ever use a dick pump i have not
try one try one okay
all
right left somebody's coming to you
almost like a mentor yeah like you got
to try it but he might not have she
wouldn't have any issues like that so
like i don't you know he might be he
might be totally nice do you jerk off
all day long
no okay
no that might not be as big a problem
i'm on like a day three right now oh
yeah on purpose or just
happened yeah yeah yeah yeah and day
three on purpose like how could you go
three days no but i'd be like are you
trying to usually day three is
usually day three i'm gonna come yeah
yeah yeah
you can feel like these images oh when i
get home
[Laughter]
i'm gonna be [ __ ] moaning in this
uber weird sippy and empathy
yeah that type of stuff never never like
the whole like
yeah i didn't like that does nothing for
me it's just i respect the dirtiness of
the woman like she's [ __ ] what a
trooper but yeah
yeah doesn't turn me on you know my
favorite part of this whole conversation
is
shane predicted it the minute he walked
in this is exactly
where we said we were going to go well
but i see how we got here yes it means
there was a flow to it it was a sket you
asked about the sketch show and you said
the sibius so then we start talking
about that yes i don't mind it if it's a
natural flow right if we're just so
quiet and all of a sudden go so you're
watching any porn like yeah that's
horrible yeah but this did kind of flow
we can click off the sybian um images
but yeah
you were uh you posted a mysterious
instagram very recently in a green neon
green tank top
and it made me big things coming yeah
man no it's just this shane gillis must
have some real big stuff going on just a
funny catch
[Laughter]
the next one's going to be stay tuned if
it's going to be me doing nothing again
playing video games in a neon green tank
top going great camps by the way
good camp thank you big news coming big
news coming it looks like it's fun it
looks like a business meeting yeah
that's what you got to do you got to
post on instagram you got to say
stay
tuned major things headed this way yeah
and then all the comics come up to you
at the seller and then
congratulations
that's a great idea is right by the way
there's anything that makes you want to
[ __ ] burn your agent alive more than
when you're talking about something and
they go stay tuned like we're coming i
[ __ ] hate stay tuned is it true
usually never
never it's never true
also if somebody posts big things headed
this way yeah yeah you hope it's a truck
nothing yeah
yeah that's a that's a depression post
when you realize there's just nothing
happening you're seeing good there's
another one you'll like could you close
this
and go scroll down a little keep going
there's one with a tiger
that one
people thought this was real which was
pretty great let's see i went through my
darkest time oh my god i can already
like
i went through my darkest time alone
so
so sorry if i act like so sorry if i act
like i don't need your help but thank
you to the select of you that stood by
me and helped me find the courage to
pick myself back up and people were
responding like we love you dude
beach trip 2020.
yeah that's good stuff that's funny that
makes me very happy yeah it's very just
to get like tom green being like i love
you shane stay keep your head up stay
strong just being nice people being nice
you feel bad when it's like people that
you know tom green made me sad you
tricked him into being nice yeah yeah
it's very it's uh that makes me happy
that's a that's a great great thing
because that really is a revolting oh
yeah hey man i saw what you posted was
powerful
there were two sets of footprints shut
up
[Laughter]
yeah that's really uh that's upsetting
yeah my my buddy billy he's good at that
he's good at i'll let him handle my
social media and he'll come up with
awful things like the most cringy
and i'm like at the time i'm like yeah
it's funny and then the next day i wake
up like [ __ ] dude because people believe
it's serious yeah people don't get it
hey man are you okay no
yeah no i thought it was funny i thought
yeah i got a hold of my instagram story
it was me like holding a bud light in
front of a pool and it was like if it
could only be this simple
[ __ ] like that
it's so funny oh i i did it last night i
was at the [ __ ] uh
i was at the uh the cellar and uh i was
with uh colin keith robinson and greg
rogel
and gr gregor ogel is just sitting there
and he goes since the panda or whatever
because i've been eating like a [ __ ]
pint of ice cream a day and i and i
looked at him and i said
i go oh god i would kill to be that way
colin goes thanks soccer mom
and i was like oh my god i really said i
wasn't kidding when i said it i was just
it was my first reaction
what a [ __ ] soccer mom [ __ ] i was you
me both my friend
yeah but that was one i recognized when
i said that to greg i didn't realize it
it's always been yeah colin realizing it
before you yeah but he was 100 right it
was a soccer mom thing to say that's bad
oh it killed me that way [ __ ] yourself
oh man well by the way we've been
talking about the podcast matt and
shane's secret podcast is available
weekly on all major platforms as well as
youtube you guys doing it on video now
yeah and patreon right and patreon yeah
patreon is doing really really well what
do you do on patreon is it an extra
episode or what do you put up hey do one
regular one extra that's great it's only
a dollar video or not patreon yeah
there's there's video yeah
and is it yeah you so you just have a
dollar or more if you want if you want
to just you know you can do as much as
you want right it's like a museum do
whatever but it's a dollar dude so
there's only one there's not like tears
no well there are matt added some we
added some tears i feel like you've
created if you would like you know all
can mean you're supposed to have a brand
right like what you're i feel like you
can't do anything that you care about
because you've conditioned your audience
to be like that's dumb dude yeah yeah
we were like embarrassed to do one ad
read we were like we're [ __ ] selling
yeah we [ __ ] up so bad dude
financially i mean we have like 20 30
000 patrons yeah
right it's one dollar
[ __ ] up
yeah because they would have paid five
yeah yeah you could have had five times
the money yeah and you could have done
one extra episode a week and then maybe
like an extra half hour thing or yeah
the amount like there are people who
have patreons that like most people who
have a one to five dollars a one dollar
tier on patreon is usually like you
don't get anything yeah like just this
is just support for the show thanks and
you're like you could have everything
yeah we [ __ ] up you can have
everything we offer but yeah you do i
mean
people love you because
you don't care
but you're not then you can't care yeah
right you can't yeah you can't do
anything to better yourself ever but i
mean it is genuine like i i and it
you don't want to [ __ ] be a promoting
guy
right but that's the thing i found out
is the guys that do all the promoting
and all that they don't [ __ ] love it
right you know right it's a reality like
this is what we do this is the business
part of the job like yeah you got to do
it like i look at like things like hey
even in the 70s carlin and prior went on
the tonight show they did tv appearances
to promote like you have to it's a part
of
what we do yeah and if the industry or
however you want to say it is not
you're going to have to promote yourself
right and uh yeah there's been a lot of
guy like schultz was is very helpful
with that he's great
he's amazing man he's really giving it
he helps everybody yes he's been so he
helped with the sketch show he made so
much and he like i remember telling him
like i don't want to [ __ ] have to
promote he's like well guess what
dumbass
you have to promote yeah like it's not
like comedy central's buying this
because then they would do the promoting
and you get to sit there because we've
lied to ourselves that promotion somehow
compromises integrity but it really
doesn't if it's your [ __ ] and you're
just going hey look there's a million
comics so i'm just this is what i'm
doing it's not there's no lack of
integrity and promotion and the audience
generally isn't doesn't sit there and go
like oh what did you become they're like
oh you're promoting a thing that you
created like you should believe in this
yeah we like this yeah people people
like will uh will get mad at guys
because they misunderstand what
integrity and tell you if you're doing
it every if all you do is promote and
it's always [ __ ] that you hate that
you've done that's different yeah but
yeah andrew is much more giving than i'd
be in his position he's amazing
because he did it better than everybody
he did it way before everybody with the
constant post and leading up to the
special but man you text him he'll call
you up hey man let's see and he tries to
walk you through it he's really really
good with that hey jim man you know i'm
working on this thing do you have any
advice you got to figure that out yeah
dude
yeah let me call you later because right
now i'm doing something never never
yes i'm working on my brand which is
blink yourself out of all acting work
yeah that's uh that's yeah that's hard
the promoting's hard it's embarrassing
so it's like yeah do the work right
there's supposed to be one at least one
difficult part because otherwise it's
just like i just get to [ __ ] around and
get money for it yeah you know there
should be something that you don't enjoy
about it
well shane gillis uh
you got one show left for the weekend of
february 17th through 19th comedy
connection east providence rhode island
get there for the sunday
9 30 show but then after that you'll be
in salt lake city at the end of february
and then in march levity live in west
niagara comedy works in denver zaney's
in nashville in april you can go to
shanem
gillis.com and of course
matt and shane's secret podcast is
available on all platforms and i would
join the patreon since it's
priced aggressively yeah one dollar one
dollar